go to a party with 50 people in it
there's a psychopath a full-blown
psychopath there there's probably five
borderline Psychopaths there they're not
going to kill you a rape you or maybe
even take your money but they're going
to manipulate the situation make you
look bad or use you in some way
something bad is going to happen and if
you sense that people have a sense that
something is wrong with somebody you
walk away you don't fight these guys
because they're masters at manipulation
a psychopath in its simplest form is an
intraspecies predator a human that is a
predator on other humans it's hard to
look at the actual behavior of a
psychopath and say that thing is
psychopathic or not because Psychopaths
will come to the rescue of people can I
help you up man they can see the outward
behaviors and they just can mimic it to
get along but fundamentally they don't
feel it you know some psychopathic
traits or what goes along with it or it
can be very advantageous first of all
you're fearless you walk into a room you
own everybody and you look like your own
everybody and they let you own you
because you have that that aura around
you that charisma that light that's why
we elect people presidents because they
have that light around them another
thing is they're kind of the oh you're
not very susceptible to pain it's the
pain doesn't bother and also when you're
caught doing something you have no tells
you could be caught red-handed
you know having an affair with somebody
and you can say no that's not me it's
like you're going to believe me or your
lying eyes you know that's and so it's
this the ability to lie without any
tells because in fact it doesn't cause
any anxiety
two main areas of brain of a psychopath
that are not regulated correctly its
orbital cortex and the amygdala orbital
cortex is involved in inhibiting your
behavior now the amygdala on the other
hand really causes behavior and normally
they're in balance they inhibit each
other now in a psychopath they're both
turned off so they don't inhibit each
other and they don't regulate it so the
normal balance of animal drives and your
social interactions your morality are
not right that's never right I mean
there's a time for aggression there's a
time for killing even so time for sex
and part of it is how the rest of the
brain is able to tell your orbital
cortex the social context is correct
now Psychopaths don't have that they're
doing things completely out of context
out of social context and that's the
problem usually the question is what
percent do you think it's due to
genetics and what percent is due to
environment and it turns out not to be
the great question to ask because the it
looks like the answer is if you are born
with the biological markers for
psychopathy for example that is the
genetics in the altered brain pattern
early on if you are a susceptible kid
then environment means everything it
means a lot maybe 80% because those kids
can be really thrown off track and they
can be helped by a good environment too
back in the early 90s some of my college
was studying these killers real bad guys
but some serial killers nest to get guys
and they asked me to come in to look at
the brains so I put myself and some
other people in his normals I got to the
last scan and I looked at it and it was
like completely pathological and I told
the technician I said you got this mixed
up this obviously you know a psychopath
or one of the killers we just mix the
pile up go check it let me check the
machine and everything it came back he
goes no it's one of these controls and
so when I pulled back the name that was
covering you know the tag covering the
name of course it was my name on it and
it had been laughs about that you know
we were so busy I kind of blew it off
which seems incredible you know most
people go we got to be kidding but I
said I Know Who I am I'm not a
psychopath there's something wrong with
the date or it's the you something's
wrong I mean within a year and a half
all the other genetics came back and I
had all the genetic markers for violence
and you know this poor empathy and
everything associated psychopathy so the
two main biological markers I still
laughed at it well it was until about
2010 I was invited to give a talk in
Oslo Norway and they talked to me for a
few hours and my data and they said oh
by the way you're probably borderline
psychopath about what they go that's the
first time I took it seriously because
these people didn't know me they were
just going from the scientific dated
from interviewing me and that was the I
when I flew back that's when everything
changed so I asked my wife I said don't
tell me anything now I'm not going to be
mad and I did that to my close friends
and family
they also the same thing so extreme
narcissist you're the extreme you know
be very aggressive and on and on you're
cold and very fortunate you know I was
grew up in a wonderful family and in
those jeans were never really triggered
in a bad direction even though I have
those traits they didn't go far south
because I should be a really bad guy
you